alright let's just odd out my arm you
know that means you know I don't look at
my arms whoa yeah yeah
everybody in the house say hey oh hey
saying when this side you call that a a
oh this is an air hey free fallin AMA
free by best position
oh now my head is okay I don't really
need it any other gums I don't know why
I picked Indiana Jones guy he's kind of
gay the black guy the cut after America
I am so sorry
yeah this metaphor you see that metaphor
and yes of course it's only a flesh
wound
ah oh sorry
dad I'm sorry I double satrap on Santa
Quadra never really difficult all right
like that like a boss son of a [ __ ]
oh don't rape me while I'm dead I hate
with you oh yes yes yes I like this a
lot
[Music]
[ __ ] you daddy like two seconds if
ascetic little [ __ ]
ha shut up John why in my backed out of
all places I became a triangle a moving
triangle a mobile founder triangle oh no
dad can we do what we practiced earlier
okay but only this time if you shut up
for one entire map that's the deal all
right
okay okay whatever you say no chicken I
say
[Music]
how's it going my name is hope you
enjoyed this happy wheels montage number
two as always if you enjoyed please take
the time to give this video a like and a
favor
it's always much appreciated also be
sure to share this video with your bros
and also hit the subscribe button up
there to you in the bro army you won't
regret i'm also gonna give away another
set of happy wheels special t-shirt
there'd be one one comment down below
alright here comes your brother
[Music]
no that's better
nah all right son you see this [ __ ] you
see this front flip I didn't hear
anything
actually go